we just showed our indeed we could do
any damn thing we want to do
that's uh bruce arians you know if
that's one of those quotes where
if i had seen it attributed to no coach
i'd know that it was him yes
that's it's that's very few that would
say that right no doubt about it but
hey i don't know if i totally buy that
comment there
but i do think they found something
yesterday i will say that right off the
bat as we
start our monday morning here at 8 a.m
you know hey quite honestly well you
know
they just got a better ship than you
guys you know that was my first super
live
the better ship award you know viking
ships are nice but it just can't mess
with the buccaneer ship the cannons you
know everything just beat your viking's
butt
uh but i'm starting there do you want to
start there or what you want to go there
i mean your setup is just mentioning
it's eight o'clock you don't even say
what time zone it's in you don't even
say what the name of that
show is we already did that what did
they got to hear it again fast right
through it
well we're resetting at the top of a new
hour it's the second hour of this monday
edition of pft live i'm just busting
my jobs and i'm i'm i'm very
appreciative that you were careful to
enunciate
ship yes when you said it right five
times
quickly right you never know you never
know you never know you never know
that or with you you do know you do know
that it will eventually
it will eventually come out differently
uh you that's it you're gonna rub my
face in it right out of the gate
like i didn't know all week long
i didn't say all week long what was
gonna happen
i knew what was gonna happen and i don't
care
the vikings outplayed the buccaneers
early i knew
that it was going to happen they weren't
going to be able to stop that offense
and the
the vikings offense was not going to be
able to sustain it and when you have a
kicker
who can't make any kicks that just makes
it even more likely that that's going to
be the outcome chris
no you're right i mean well i mean you
said it they blew it
the vikings blew it they had a chance
early on in that football game to be up
double digits
at the least uh but they didn't take
advantage of that and i feel like you
know we talk about one of these games
every week where
one team dominates early but they you
look up and you go well
they're dominating because they're only
up nine nothing or six nothing
that's not dominating and you're gonna
let that team then get their mojo back
and
tampa did eventually and you know to
what bruce aryan said too
you know and again i'm i'll be excited
to watch this film
but i think they've done some of the
stuff we've been talking about really
you know just hey run the ball a little
bit two tight end sets
play action and run the ball on first
and second down you know
get into third and you know like coach
dungey said last night
third and manageable third and eight or
eight or less
and then brady can make the right
decision and shotgun with those weapons
and bam bam bam bam but
you know to me that's their most
effective way of playing football
and maybe they can build on that because
brady as we see his arm is still
top-notch
if you just make him feel comfortable in
the pocket
that there's not going to be people
hitting them then he's more comfortable
and he's willing to pull the trigger for
those deeper type throws
it did look a little rough early though
when the vikings had the better of the
play there was that third down there was
one where he missed rob gronkowski the
first drive
that the buccaneers had it and then
chris gone would wide open and would
have been gone for a touchdown and tom
brady
plenty of time in the pocket to set up
to find a receiver you suggested
yesterday he sticks
with mike evans and gronk maybe a little
longer than he should before he moves
off
right but he he eventually saw chris
godwin and he just sailed it
10 feet over his head if any other
quarterback did that we would have
laughed for an hour about it yeah he
missed a few throws
he did he missed a few throws in the
game early on where we were just like
man what that he's wide open
you know but he he found his groove
certainly and they're talented enough
too as a football team
to overcome that you know they are oh
hey wait we missed a 15-yard 20-yard
completion
no big deal you know we got other guys
here we got a good aggressive play
caller we'll get another chance at it
and
they take advantage of it they are they
hang in there
you know even through that ugly spot
like you talked about early
you know their defense found their way
it looked like man dalvin cook's going
to easily run for 100 yards in this
football game he's blowing them out the
water but the defense kind of shored up
and we'll see you know tampa still one
of those teams a lot of potential i
don't know where they are right now but
yesterday was a good start by them um
you know beating up on
your minnesota vikings here's where they
are and it's very simple it's falcons
lions falcons so they should win their
last three games they should finish 11
and 5.
bruce aryan said last week it doesn't
matter if we don't have a home game in
the playoffs because there aren't going
to be fans at these games anyway so
you know they may have to go to lambeau
field
and play the packers there tom brady and
aaron rodgers
i would sign up for that if it
eventually happens they may have to go
play new orleans again
i'd like to see a round three after the
saints so roundly handled them
especially in the second
go-round so uh yeah they're they're
going to be an intriguing team in the
playoffs because
pretty sure they're going to get in i'd
say the percentage i can't remember i
think it's like nine to five
it's like 95. pretty high yeah 95. i'd
say that i'd say they're in good shape
right
and i think they're going to be a tough
team to beat when january rolls around
and you know the big the big statistic
that
that kind of jumped off the screen to me
when we had the comparison up
zero sacks of brady six of kirk cousins
yes
if you're gonna sack kirk cousin six
times the passing game isn't working
the offense isn't working well enough
and when you throw in the fact that they
had their chance to go up double digits
early and they blew it thanks to dan
bailey
missing kicks uh that's that and shaq
barrett who had two sacks of kirk
cousins yesterday
said to me with a laugh he wasn't
serious about it but he said tell the
field goal kicker we appreciate him
and uh they should because the vikings
surely don't at this point and i will be
surprised if dan bailey isn't cut today
by the vice
i would i would think so right i mean
you know your
your vikings are not out of it they're
they're not as as
they're out of it it's over seventeen
percent you're saying
the story huh yeah yeah they're out of
it
here's what'll happen here's what will
happen no here's what will happen
the they'll beat the bears they'll beat
the saints and then they'll lose to the
lions that's my prediction
oh okay so they'll beat the bears and
then they'll lose the lions
no they'll beat the saints christmas day
they'll beat the saints and cause
everyone to believe that they're going
to make it into the playoffs some way
somehow and then they'll lose the lines
week 17. that's
awesome all right you sound better oh he
doesn't love them today everybody
i said that i sound practical
okay so give me uh all right so enough
about this game give me a new uh
nice superlative all right it's the it's
the five finger discount award are you
familiar with the five finger discount
you had money you never had to shop left
not that i ever did
but that sounds like you might have the
[ __ ] no
possibly the five sack discount the fi
hassan reddick what a story this was and
it just kind of happened like
wait a minute he's got three wait a
minute he's got four wait him and he's
got five
five sacks on sunday against the giants
three forced fumbles
and he didn't even know he had five
sacks he told me i didn't realize until
after the game and he never had more
than
two at any level of football in his
entire
life it was incredible franchise record
most in an nfl game since 2017
five sacks and it was exactly what the
cardinals needed they were reeling they
had lost
four out of five they had lost three in
a row they had been on a five game
losing streak but for the hell murray
they were stepping into a bear trap
against a giants team that all of a
sudden was looking pretty damn good
yeah and the cardinals uh as you said
yesterday at one point they out
giants the giants they did i mean they
just
played defense and forced you know
forced turnovers by the giants and they
just played smart and didn't make any
mistakes it's kind of what the giants
have been doing to people before this
but yeah i mean that was a phenomenal
you know by vance joseph defensive
coordinator there hassan reddick they
were all over daniel jones all day long
and i mean i had a superlative he
shouldn't have been playing no exactly
i was my i was going to hit this game
next if you didn't because i was going
with you know instead of big blue it's
going to go big
ooh because it just didn't look good
okay
it didn't look good from the team
yesterday and it didn't look right with
daniel jones really
pretty early on you could tell that he
was not normal right
and i felt like it affected his play i i
don't know if that was the best thing
for the giants and
and daniel jones to have him out there
yesterday certainly and then he
re-aggravates it and who knows how bad
he'll be here going forward
but yeah the giants came out no emotions
out hit and then made some mistakes and
really dug themselves into a hole where
their offense is just not built to make
those type of comebacks and that was
enough of that after that
how many teams how many coaches how many
trainers how how
how many times does it have to happen
before people realize a hamstring injury
needs
rest period i don't know anything about
all these
highfalutin newfangled techniques for
getting a muscle to heal faster than
otherwise would
all i know is you pull your hamstring it
takes
time and usually two weeks isn't going
to be enough time to get you ready to go
back out there and play high-level
professional sports especially football
so they should have gone with colt mccoy
and now they may have to go with colt
mccoy next sunday night
and and it creates a neat little wrinkle
because mccoy once played for the browns
but who cares it's going to make the
browns a much greater
favorite in that game no if it is cold
but he did beat the seahawks
right he did beat the seahawks so maybe
there's hope i want to see
the giants at their best which i do
still think is daniel jones of course
and i want to see baker mayfield and
daniel jones go at it because didn't
like
baker mayfield talk trash about daniel
jones last year
after he got drafted so i kind of wanted
to see that but you're not going to see
daniel jones at his best
certainly and yeah the giants they can't
play that style of football yesterday
where you're going to turn the ball over
it looked like early season giants once
again it's like what what happened all
of a sudden their o-line just got
steamrolled it's like they could not
handle the speed of the front
of the arizona cardinals and it was just
chaos around daniel jones all day they
couldn't run the football
and they get a strip sack you know early
on arizona
dion lewis fumbles the kick return and
the giants are down six nothing before
they can figure out what the hell is
going on there and
and that was that for the most part what
impressed me about the cardinals and
this is something that reddick told me
that they they were spirited they were
aggressive
they were they were locked in all week
in practice like you know
the the teams that know they have to get
a win
you don't all of a sudden show up on
sunday and respond to that
no you work at it all week right the the
the traces of it are
there's no traces of it it's obvious to
anyone who's paying attention
that this team is ready to go we find
out about it on sunday
but it's wednesday thursday friday where
the team develops the sense that they
are going to have the sense of urgency
that they need in order to in the
cardinals case reverse that losing
streak and get back into the seventh
spot which they now
can we put the graphic up they now have
a much better percentage chance
of getting to the playoffs and they did
a week ago by virtue of getting that win
so uh they they now are you sold on it
though you think they're gonna make it i
mean you know they still got look at
that 61
would you have guessed that they'd be a
61 percent i'm shocked at this point i'm
shocked especially with the fact that
they have the seahawks and the rams on
there
uh i don't know it's the rams in the who
am i missing the 49ers they still have
on there
which i don't think are good matchups
for arizona where i look at that and go
they they i mean if you made me better
they're going to lose both of those
football games
but you know again the other problem is
the teams below them
certainly aren't that special and your
your minnesota team can lose the last
three
chicago we know how dicey they are so
i guess i do understand why arizona's at
61 because
the other team's got some tough games
and none of them are consistently good
anyways
all right uh who's got the next
superlative oh i think it's me kind of
uh yeah i think i'm gonna uh you know
i'm gonna go with those uh run
run those horses yeah
yeah talk about the indianapolis colts
because when the indianapolis colts
run the ball a little bit and show that
they're gonna stay a little patient with
it
it changes their football team around
you know it's a little bit like the
brady and the tampa bay thing
you can't expect philip rivers to just
drop back and carry you like he's in
this prime still
and he's gonna be throwing balls 50
yards down the field the people around
him and all that no
that's not going to happen they need to
play through the run they still have a
really good offensive line
we saw yesterday but those running backs
you know jonathan taylor nahim heinz
it's a great one-two punch
and i mean this is the type of stuff
they're they're capable of doing if
you're
if you're watching here i mean just a
little inside zone play where
he finds a hole sticks his foot in the
ground and hits it at a million miles
per hour but
it just makes everything better and i
think the fact with
you know run those horses i mean with
the running game
and then the other thing that's happened
lately with the cults
that i think has flown very much under
the radar
they're healthy and the fact ty helton
is back
it adds another dimension to their
offense because now it's like oh wait
you know we didn't really have a
receiver we have to worry about but now
we have to worry about him and that's
going to help the run game and it helps
philip rivers because he's got a go-to
guy
it's going to help out michael pittman
jr now you're going to see him open a
whole lot more
so the colts are one of those teams
again i know it's a little inconsistent
but man
when they're on their game they do a lot
of impressive things and yesterday they
played some good football on both sides
of the ball got some turnovers
everything that was a good win for them
out in las vegas
see my superlative coming out of that
game would have been matt eberflus is on
notice award because this virus is going
around now the raiders beat the jets
greg williams gets fired as defensive
coordinator
then the colts beat the raiders and paul
gunther gets fired as defensive
coordinator
and so if the texans would beat the
cults maybe matt eberflusk gets fired as
defensive coordinator
highly unlikely but there's definitely
something going around
and the thing about gunther and i'm
going to be writing something about this
after this yeah pft
um the the raiders
had and and you can check this out on
the film
chris they had a guy named chris smith a
six foot one 266 pound defensive end
playing nose tackle for much of the game
good luck good luck doing that against
the indianapolis colts with that blue
wall up front
right and one of the reasons they had to
go with smith they tried to sneak daniel
ross through waivers last week
because they needed a spot for trent
brown when he came off of the coveted
list and they lost
the only problem is the jaguars took him
right so they were completely
overmatched at the interior defensive
line yesterday
and lo and behold you're playing the
colts and they ran
roughshod all over you you shouldn't be
surprised no you should
be surprised i'm surprised on a short
week
that you'd fire paul gunther you're
playing thursday night against the
chargers and you're firing paul gunther
what are they thinking this is john
gruden
acting on impulse and no one in the
building to tell him not to do well
i mean i mean i don't know mike i i have
no knowledge of this but i mean
what do you think happened i mean
something happened something
happened there was an argument there was
a a a
a a a an argument about you know the
beliefs and what you should do or how
the defense there has to be
that just doesn't happen like you said
on this type of week too
a short week you know and you're still
in the playoff race
there there has to be something more
than we just came into the locker room
and oh
man we they were good on third down and
ran the ball on us you're fired
no i just don't think so there has to be
something more to that story there
that is such uh just an abrupt
thing to happen and you know to your
point too the raiders defensive lines
that's the number one thing they gotta
fix there's just not one really
big time player there their best player
is crosby he's very good
but he's not a superstar they need to
get that's where they got to spend their
money this offseason and resources but
uh that well they've put so much money
into the offense yeah and not nearly
enough into the defense so how do you
expect paul gunther to turn chicken
salad out of that
but you have me fascinated now the gears
are turning about all the things that
may have gone down
got to between john gruden and paul
gunther
in the locker room in the coaching
office whether it was physical
whether it was verbal you know little
mark columbo and joe judge
action you never know but but all we do
know is we
we we we we won't we won't see
paul gunther this thursday uh and based
on your experience
with john gruden did you ever see that
kind of stuff where he gave it to his
assistants the way he gave it to his
coaches or to his players excuse me well
yeah he's tough on them
he's tough there's no doubt about it i
mean he's he questions everybody he's
gonna question himself
too though it's not like it's like
unwarranted where he all of a sudden he
just rides one coach and
you're like oh man is really you know
being unrealistic and crazy with this
guy
no you know i i don't know where it went
you know my history with those type of
things is
maybe the head coach said something and
then maybe the defensive coordinator
or somebody goes off right they go off
and then that forces the coach's hand to
be like
okay but you don't want to be here or
whatever i mean that that would be my
like two sense of that that i just i
gotta think something went down i got to
it just it's
too too crazy of a decision right now
it puts you in a tough spot and now rod
marinelli is thrust into the position of
being the defensive coordinator
with three days to get ready to
coordinate the defense and
uh there's a chance that that that may
not go all that well all right
next one from me this is vindication
colon can we please not talk about the
2017
draft for at least one week now the
mitchell trubisky story
by mitchell trubisky yeah uh you know
and we joked about this at one point
last week i can't remember when
because i really didn't serious
seriously believe it was going to happen
but from trubisky's perspective having
to hear about
the bears trading up to take him when
they could have had patrick mahomes they
could have had desean watson they could
have traded down and gotten to sean
watson
for one moment in time for one day in
his life
trubisky was able to shut that crap
up and they looked great and the texans
looked horrible
romeo cornell told the sideline reporter
of the game we're lucky
that we're only down by 23 points at
halftime that's not amazing that's not a
glowing endorsement of his team
so uh kudos to true biscuit you know who
knows where his career is going to go
from here
who knows where the bears are going to
go from here uh but at least it's
something
that he can say for one day i was able
to get
this 2017 draft talk
out of my head and i was able to go out
and play well against one of the guys
the bears
could have had if they didn't take me
yeah that's right i mean
you know good for him he takes a lot of
crap we know that
you know and not deserving of all of it
definitely not because we've seen
with or without him their offense has
been really crappy but the last two
weeks mike
uh and i talked about this a little on
my podcast last week
their offense has changed a little bit i
i swear
that they heard coach dungy against the
packers on sunday night football
and coach dungy said i think that they
should get underneath the center and run
the ball
and be a run and bootleg and play action
football team
and i swear ever since then i've seen
them underneath the center and doing
that more and more i think they
somebody went back and went wait coach
dungey said this about us why don't we
try this aspect
and i've seen more formations and
personnel sets and things over the last
two weeks i know they lost to the lions
two weeks ago
it wasn't because of their offense and
yesterday was really impressive it
really was
i mean the bears are they're not out of
this as crazy as they've been
inconsistent in this losing streak
they got a chance to still sneak in this
damn thing
here's what fascinates me because the
head coach isn't going to go back and
watch the tv copy they rarely watch the
tv copy of their own games they watch
the film
right so who was it somebody said they
heard that right
was this like ted phillips that you know
or this i mean who is it that because it
was a road game
yeah right so it's somebody who didn't
travel to the game
i know watching it on tv listening to it
and he's able to communicate it through
to the coaching staff and the coaching
staff actually heeds it instead of
saying get the hell out of here we know
how to run our team
so uh uh encouraging that
that matt nagy ultimately was willing to
make that change and
it worked at least for one day and
you're right they're not out of it
elimination game as a practical matter
coming up this weekend in minnesota
against the vikings yeah no i know it's
uh
their defense i mean we know their
defense is damn good it was dominant
yesterday and of course hey listen
i i'm happy with what i saw but
that is the houston texans i mean and
some weeks it's just like we only know
they're out there because they have a
pulse on defense we're just like oh yeah
they're out there look they're breathing
i mean but they're they've had weeks
this year where it's so bad it's
hard to evaluate other teams offenses
off of them yesterday might have been
one of those days but either way
good for mitchell trubisky good for the
bears they finally get off the schneid
and maybe they can turn this thing
around we'll see where it goes um
anything else got any more yeah i got
one more i got the uh
i've seen enough i've seen enough award
i've seen enough we've talked about this
game already
i have a question yes i have a question
have you seen it i have i really have
because it's gotten personal to me i'd
like my friend
kyle shanahan to bench nick mullins i've
seen enough get him the hell out
what else do we got to do how many games
are we going to lose this year
because of nick mullins i just don't
understand it
i really don't he was pitiful yesterday
turnover machine
missing receivers that are open over the
middle of the football field
i mean you can pin a number of games to
them this year and go
no if they just had a little bit better
quarterback play other than nick mullins
they're going to win that game or it's
going to be very close
but he is over matched and it's just i i
just it's over for me i i
i see some of the good but it's never
good when it needs to be it's always
good like halfway through the first
quarter when the game is not competitive
when the game gets tough all of a sudden
it's really below average and
you know yesterday if he just doesn't
turn the ball over and plays the game
close to the vest they're going to win a
defensive struggle
but they let the washington defense
score 14 points washington's offense
couldn't move the ball really
but that you know his carelessness with
the football and everything there
i just i don't know i just i'll be
shocked if they come back to the the
the drawing board this week with him as
a starting quarterback gotta think cj
beathard is the guy here
for the last three weeks of the year or
jimmy garoppolo if he's back healthy
it's funny every time i see nick mullens
take his helmet off he just looks like a
guy who
is an actor playing a football player
from a movie in the 80s if that makes
anything
and it probably makes none it does i
think it does
when he pulls his helmet off i feel like
there's i
know what you mean it's like there's
background music and he's trying really
hard
a sweaty playoff game in like high
school football with
some cheesy 80s music behind it i agree
stefan
georgeovich stefan georgeovich you know
who that is no stuff in georgia
i do not that was the character tom
cruise played in all the right movies oh
right right and pipe it's been a long
time
i'll tell you i've spent plenty of time
in western pennsylvania there folks
there is no place called
m pipe i can guarantee you that
i've driven around yeah there is no ant
pipe but uh yeah
uh stefan georgeovich uh uh who who had
something go down in the locker room and
got fired by uh
his head coach he wasn't the defensive
coordinator but he got fired during the
game
now i have to go back and watch that
move i hadn't thought about that movie
in years so nick mullins thank you
or something else for putting that movie
in my head now and i have to go watch
all the right moves okay
uh uh let's take a break i was gonna do
vindication part two
andy dalton goes back to cincinnati and
beats the bengals as the quarterback of
the cowboys but no matter what jerry
jones says
about the cowboys nobody cares i'm sorry
we didn't pay homage to listen jerry
jones actually tried to make the
argument on friday with a straight face
that it's a good thing that they got
flexed out of next sunday night's game
so sure nobody
nobody cares about the cowboys sure
other things we just need to throw no we
just gotta throw a little love to the
history maker
you know and derek henry i mean what he
did again yesterday
that's insanity and the membranity i
don't know when you
up walter payton jim brown and barry
sanders for most 200 no ladainian thomas
is not walter payton excuse me
for most 200 yard rushing games with
multiple tds
that's just that's a list that i mean
come on that's uh
legend legend legend oh hey derek henry
oh welcome to the legend club
uh it just he's amazing what he does the
way they play
the speed of the size in which he runs
everything so
just wanted to say congratulations to
him i we've told him this to his face
and i believe it he's the modern day jim
brown
once you get him going he is unstoppable
and chris
1532 yards rushing with three games to
go
it it it will take
well derek henry we it'll take
it'll take three derrick henry games for
derrick henry to become the all-time
season rushing leader he got the texas
the lions and the packers
none of them are good on run defense so
that can be interesting
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports